[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
alright hello everyone happy Monday
apologies for the delay they're like
couple minute delay it's all my fault -
really blame - yeah director blame it
yeah pretty much but yeah we're we're
sorting out something on the site to get
it over somewhere else long story short
we got Shadow of the Colossus the remake
essentially on PlayStation 4 and we're
gonna check it out Mike one of my
favorite games yeah what if I don't rank
it'd be like number two or three common
lists so I haven't played this I'll be
honest up front that's okay I can live
on the ps2 so you can inline me upon our
journey here I'll just skip this this is
not this is the intro of rolling before
the menu don't worry well we'll watch
the intro see a little bit of backstory
yeah obviously like I'm sure many people
know Fumito wait up probably butchering
a little bit from a team eco back in the
day they did eco and then they did shout
the Colossus and then some of his team
went over to that new studio they made
to make the Last Guardian two years ago
so this is their best game in my opinion
again it's not the same studio but it's
many of the same people do normal yeah
yes this is October 20 sorry October
2005 so between 12 and 13 years ago so
we picked a performance mode just so you
guys know for how to soon better frame
rates that emphasize right over yeah
resolution I think so and like display
and stuff like that but you could pick
cinematic mode if you chose to it's one
of those like games that has those
options I think master hunters gonna be
like that too where you can kind of pick
like yeah like kind of game along play
shape bump up body yeah it's not really
it's not spoiler warning I mean we're
gonna just watch the game game and
people who played it and know and maybe
who know it's a very minimal story
although there is stuff does happen
later on as you play more that I will
not spoil here so we are sony has
allowed us to play up until the 8th
colossus i highly doubt we're gonna get
that far not i mean
I haven't played this game in a while
but also be as people know these kalasa
I can take a while yeah the first guitar
is war will take like it's fine
around the first few will take like five
to ten minutes keep going I mean
obviously you get to the last boss and
it can be like an hour 45 minutes or
whatever you wanna say sorry I went to
turn down our fan in case that uh you
know this room gets a little hot
sometimes is cyborg man was just asking
is cinematic mode on regular ps4 to or
not sure I would I would have to think
so but I can't confirm or deny that for
you since I haven't actually tested it
and we're playing a pro right now yeah
so this is wander on his horse agro and
it looks good though yeah it does
you the colossi lining the wall right
there at a statue to them
[Music]
so hey there's a few people in our
office that didn't get the chance to
play this back in the day I'm excited to
see what they think
cuz at the time it was super weird to
just have 16 bosses essentially and no
like enemies in the overworld because
toward wow he looks really different
later in the game you're travelling for
quite a while to get to some of the
colossi mm-hmm so just so people know
this is done by Blue Point and I think
it's Japan studios blue points worked on
a bunch of other stuff you're totally
against them eco shower classic
collection got a war collection now your
salad legacy right yeah Uncharted
collection as well so pretty cool stuff
it's only for the pro according to James
static oh you don't think our word for
it take it you said that based on an
interview so if you take his word for it
yeah cool how long are you guys gonna
play for Rob roughly 90 minutes give or
take if he's like mid-fight we'll finish
it well like pretty much finish it's not
like a hard stop for us just when it
reaches a logical gonna stop yeah we're
allowed to play till the eighth Colossus
there we're not gonna get to that and
then though I'm excited I got a review
copy that I'm not renewing it but I got
a review copy and you're planning on
potential feature yeah we're doing a few
things you know we have also for the
person that asked about fighters that
reviews up ready with full roll you
could you be cool
so I undo you little [ __ ] I use the EULA
called Allah Olek all Islam
cause it's very cool so call I'm no
screw to thank each other Camarena was
you a dealers also few houses is view a
color kids adore you Lola is Lee's force
I am is pretty cute you will all quicker
she's out in a coma
kind of
well sorry
and I used to be like I don't yeah you
affect that uh I want to say it's like
almost like the a DD yeah oh we were
playing on a program hey guys
but you can't play on a ps4 as well once
it comes out comes out February the 6th
she's in a couple weeks we can do up to
8 Donnie fear we're probably only gonna
get to like three or four as my
convention that's fair Casey yeah if you
guys haven't played this and you're
looking forward to it you might want to
be beware of spoilers here but you know
I'm interested like if I still have
similar I mean I'm not gonna the same
feelings I did the first time I played
it but in 20 and 2.5 keep saying it's
2005 when it came out that was right
around the first God of War and I
remember I got both of them and I was
playing them and obviously they're very
different games but remember this being
super just like monumental and like the
kind of games I'd like to play after
this I mean it's super minimal Istres
again I was used to like open-world
games with tons of enemies yeah there is
a review embargo I don't know that it's
publicly yeah well there will be
previews up throughout the week and
streams and stuff no 16 no 16 bosses
with five ten-minute cheats that's
completely wrong the first few might be
fat 5 10 minutes each the ones later on
can be up to an hour
dang really yeah the final boss is the
biggest Colossus in the game is uh they
said like his back he said he's a flying
he's a sign that didn't really right
there's a few flying colossi but he is
his back is essentially like the width
of a four-lane highway and the wings are
60
this is okay they're trying to bring her
back to life
yeah essentially you can spoil this game
100% later on when you start to find out
what's really going on so I guess it is
kind of up to interpretation like any
movie story like this but stuff concrete
stuff happens oh yeah of course we gotta
go do something I would mm-hmm
nothing comes for free Last Guardian I
think well I'm not the right person to
ask it's one of my favorite games and I
did not like The Last Guardian I
recognized that values again I know a
lot of people speak highly of it also
very different games
you're doing yeah so unlike the
collection that came out on ps3 this is
like it a total remaster by Blue Point
which they often do so this obviously
you can tell right away it looks really
good but the ps3 version that took heavy
losses and eco and combine them was that
blue point as well the ps3 collection
yeah it was them that was blue I believe
so yeah yeah cool yeah but yeah this is
like actually remastered ID trough that
the true plan TB trough DT roof may be
49 it'd be hard for us to stream 4k and
for you to actually get that like
fidelity I feel like over stream but
sorry 1080 60 today boys and girls
someone asked about combat I'm sure
we'll see some of that soon enough
yeah the first few Colossus colossi are
pretty close to that's what you do you
till you navigate to them by your sword
and shine this light okay after a while
you start doing climbing clips going
into lakes sorry I'm talking over this
but there's not much in the way of
expedition it's not like they're just
telling me I have to be reading the text
either way right they're just saying I
have to hunt down these 16 Casas if I
want any chance of bringing her back
yeah
for these beings who are kind of unclear
who they are do you want to do that yeah
I probably do do what save the girl oh
yeah okay so yeah he's still got his so
players of the original overmix oh yeah
so he's got that like a long jump he can
do or just quick one people that the
original remember the controls were not
all that refined so you hold this up and
it tells you where you're going going
that way okay um so here's AA girl my
horse Lea and then you see my endurance
meter at the bottom right that can
improve over time
all right triangle that's supposed to
ride him out of here yeah sorry there we
go man get used to it ya might get off
and then just jump down and then call
him there we go whoa yeah okay so he's
wide turn
sweet sweet white
can i download it yet no the game
doesn't come out does not release until
the 6th of February we're just fortunate
enough to get a review cause we're
allowed to preview up until the 8th
colossi or 8th colossus but we probably
won't get that far we're streaming for
roughly 90 minutes give or take
depending on you know if mike is in like
a colossus fight obviously we're not
just gonna cut it short the goal will
hopefully to be to beat a couple of them
show you guys the world show you guys
some of the earlier boss or Colossus
fights pretty cool stuff then there is
some there are some parkour aspects kind
of like an action puzzle game yeah I
mentioned as you go on the game there
are far fewer of these cutscene kind of
things
I mean it's trying to set things up for
you a little bit right yeah that sounds
like a grow r2 is essentially your grip
throughout the entire game you can see
at the bottom right it starts to dwindle
Oh interesting that's like half the game
is uh managing that yeah cuz that's a
lot of the colossi have fur on them
that's how you're climbing them oh so
you can see it kind of dwindles there
ooh I like that little site for all so
that comes back and was that something
you say you get more of later you can
yeah if you find these lizards in the
overworld it did used to be pink that's
weird the grab bar so you jump hold r2
yeah you can get more of it over time
you get like health or grip HX Lexi is
that like Lexi we know well so it off
the bat it feels better than I remember
like I do remember this game being kind
of janky oh it is it like so hey what's
up Lexi okay nice so so far so so good
so again this took like what five
minutes to get to him
the first one that's the guy in our
thumbnail I think probably yeah this
guy's kind of pretty basic you see the
fur on his back and you can kinda let me
find out if we're allowed to show you
guys the option at all I got this as
well someone said the the old kind of
like stamina or endurance bar was pink
it was yet alright so wonder how I r1 is
all right
it's L to focus on the controls they're
not have not changed all that much and
food we've got a weak spot all right
she charged it up unless he's feels
man's calf
how'd you like that you could see the
endurance you can like charge up to the
to like the max and burns you have
before he takes you off
it's done now so then now there's
another spot yeah I got cinahl so you
can start finding out more are your
attacks stronger like the longer you
hold them or is it kind of basic
okay cool so I'm pressing square to
raise my sword and then square again so
now I'm gonna when you get two flat
positions like this one a recharge or
stamina one possible I think I'm just
gonna go straight up damn his fur looks
really good just on his head now I think
I did I get his shin completely laughs
sorry haha the boo
sucks or knee-jerk that a lot more
damage Wow a lot more damage yeah I mean
I am driving into a skull yeah that's
fair
and do it so yeah I mean this this boss
is pretty so I don't even need to charge
up at all barely now so keep in mind
I've even for someone who hasn't played
the game that one's pretty obvious yeah
gives you the tutorial like like I teach
you how to rest on ledges went down
116th of the way there yeah I I mean
like that kind of looks like you're
training
Colossus in a way it's like all right
find a widget like the Frog spot
Sagar salmon oh right the first ones
staggered him so now this black stuff is
where does that go oh you'll see who I
want to see oh
absorbs actually like puking him it's
game be skin gets real weird real fast
oh are we that is just like your
subconscious you can interpret it that's
so yeah I mean are we in him right now
we're being transported back to the
temple I know that oh wow okay
and then the you guys should get us
saved at the top of the tower I'm sure
the top looks even more beautiful than
the original the tower in the world or
the tower boss at the end I don't know
Lexi please expound I'm trying to find
out if we can show the iron I'll show
the options I'm trying to find out if we
can I'm pretty sure we can't be able to
I think we'd have to we'd be able to not
pause it during a stream okay we'll
check it out after this the tower you
started into what Lexi's talking about
okay can you get to the top from the
beginning again
yes so okay I don't think you need a
full grip I've beaten the game without
expanding my grip at all the first time
I played I didn't know you could find
those lizards probably just makes it
easier right Oh too soon
obviously oh that's gonna be a long time
Lexi yeah I need full grip to get to the
top got it okay yeah but thank you for
that idea we I will make sure somebody
does that Oh we destroyed one the
statues there he goes the next one is so
all of the linear or can you kind of you
know I think what you want
no it's linear in the sense that you
have to do a certain one so the next one
is always so it's always in order then
yeah in a certain order that's why I
like people will say oh the 12th
Colossus is my favorite etc they they
give you clues where they are although
the sword because the sword doesn't
always point directly to it just tells
you the direction so if it points to
this opening of Eclipse and then you
pass through it it could change so this
is like the horse looking nude but this
one teaches you how to use the bow shoot
as a the bottom of his hooves
doing out the way though I got I guess
so I think we should be fine to show the
options I'll just ask forgiveness isn't
wrong yes it'll be it'll be on me guys
started the stream late my fault you
know settings so what do we want to play
maybe or game is a game okay it's not
that performance mode motion oh we're on
yeah maybe it's a game oh we can turn
off the tutorials that's cool keep mine
I turned photo mode on just in case what
options maybe oh there you go
classic oh there you go you can go
classic guys but dynamic change on maybe
dynamic it only comes up when you are
getting hurt or yeah so how do you want
- oh no hood how did that be tough not
knowing your grip you just have said
well he does have like animations that
might show you well go classic try try
one boss on classic
where do you want to do them kind of
like I'll be classic in general all
right we can always customize later so
there you go there there's some of the
stuff you guys want to see hi oh hey I'm
gonna get like save points I believe it
does have HD r NS xia you gotta enable
it was an option that i could enable but
this isn't a 4k screen so or with HDR so
anyways I'm gonna tape yeah and also
like refills here pray before it I think
that's gonna I don't think I need this I
guess he's like saying like agro then
that's the horse's name yeah I know but
I just think of like when I think agro
in a game it's like when you've gotten
the agro six sword training okay what
are you trying to do I don't think I
need to I think it's just a refill help
okay alright let's go this one no I'll
shut up and let us see the way go uh let
me share the controls later Johnny raw
real asking how's the camera uh it's
good it's definitely loose if that makes
sense
how does it feel compared to playing it
it doesn't feel like an old hey you
it feels like I remember it but it
doesn't feel not like to its detriment
I think I'm crossing the bridge first
and then going down we said it was near
the what the key yeah it's down here in
general Oh dip that looks nice yes and
that's this camera yeah the dynamic
camera kind of hands for you I thought
your own classic what do you mean oh
that's just the house that agro knows
the way of course he knows the way give
it a little pan here just a manual
camera work yeah BAM thief I don't want
it I forgot I'm not gonna test yeah
there was no need to think so but I also
remember you can't fall off certain
ledges in it
[ __ ] you okay I did go the right way
sweet yeah give us those she's cool
later on cuz there's not always like a
little cinematic to tell you you're near
them if I remember correctly they just
kind of raise up and the screen shakes a
little bit
you can see a desert starts right there
get to get into some different biomes
you fight him on the beach yeah man this
could be so I remember this again being
I'm gonna take my bow out I remember
this being a little bit uh the camera
can be tough during this fight hopefully
now find out if got some nice there's a
midnight mode and the options let me
check this out do we get trolled there's
a midnight mode no there's a few people
that someone's at nightmare mode maybe
is it see there's an enable HDR someone
wanted controls you can change your aim
stuff yeah you want to show controls
later later when my lot of times here we
go let me check this out
yeah you're on a HUD layout here we go
there's a health I can move it don't
move it left because we're blocking
bottom-left midnight mode and audio they
said Audie why is that an audio I wonder
limit volume during loud moments so I
don't think it's midnight mode like make
it night it's limit oh now I'm good to
know there's no controls real quick so
that sure we can kind of just get that
out of the way so they're different than
it used to be yeah so grab oh but you
could change it right I saw you yeah
yeah classic so this is the old one I
actually kind of like that more jump on
triangle horses modern its control horse
it's up to you
you're the one playing I think I'm
already used to what's up dr. pickles
how are you doing today
yeah so grab is our two I'll stick with
this for now
alright number two coming up hopefully
my the cameras and as that is unexpected
it to be for this one because he's got a
very midnight mode is for when you have
kids I don't want to wake them up that's
fair
oh god thanks red eight cents so this
this right here is pretty oh sorry oh
whoops
aha
where are you that is number two number
two was that mean lizard getting close
no it was like oh so if it's yellow
you're close yeah Oh cute cutscene I
knew he was gonna break out of that I
just had a feeling
what's up 91 to 86
oh yeah that's joining a cabal yeah
actually that kind of touched on it
there's a nickname for each class but
there's also a Latin names and this one
is like Centaurus
no not Centaurus what's the bowl yeah
tarus something how he's like a horse
tart a bowl thing so you can get off
aggro for this or you could stay on him
I'm gonna what you gonna do stay on it I
gotta get my bow out first
Ola he doesn't go after you I can't I
can't tell you too much about scheme oh
you know I'm gonna get off you do you
hey am i late oh whatever
okay I did see the yellow spots though
yeah under the hoods as you had
mentioned
kind of pitter-pattering right now it's
not really doing yeah okay so you focus
on without to it's a big rock horse what
the hell was a bull oh I just have to
release our when I was thinking have to
press square once I did all right Oh
Chris
Kristen five he says it's in display
mode under filter and there's my motors
yeah if you take that out later
give me your crotch oh I'm not jumping
on the right part a my [ __ ] appears that
Mike has forgotten how to beat 2nd boss
hip hip hep oh yeah let me oh this is
nice sorry guys okay I got the me I got
it you got it yeah okay so I gotta shoot
it okay it was the knee
okay got it yeah he did not I say give
me your yeah Bob its whatever new goes
down all right I got it
he very much just that that just haha
okay
climbing the knee Oh interesting he just
get a mess up the moment get up in that
but well yeah he feels me he knows he's
in trouble he knows I'm coming for him
I'm gonna go yeah just go straight up so
that's another part like I mean okay get
up I think I can just stand him
oh we going after the bud ad that booty
you weren't joking nope dock storage but
all right here we go
so then afterwards like certain wheat
points will disappear I think I could
stand up right now
this I think I got to go to his head
again I'm gonna let go for a second
hopefully he doesn't throw me off yes
borrow or wear Oh has mentioned the
remastered one for the ps3 is just up
the resolution it made 60 F yes okay
this time was on made for ground up geez
yeah yep why did you panic I didn't all
right whatever you told my panic there I
feel like you were you're saved
like lucky save and then you're like oh
no no like I what I want to say I went
to heat shook at the last second and
tossed me off it's just the danger of
the game I guess here we go I guess yeah
I got him in the foot
sorry hey well we didn't lose that much
time I'll just go back up uh yes so the
controls still they feel better than I
remember like or they feel like I
remember so I guess that's good for a
remake as far as it's I'm not I don't
feel like I'm battling the game right
now the camera does feel a little bit
there's a little bit of junk to it but
it does feel smoother than I thought it
would which I guess is good alright I
think I got a jump spot alright all
things yeah okay gotta go down for a
second okay so this could be
I'm gonna reset this
I gotta go a while here
it's riding in a closet it's no problem
do you think it's all the way in the
front hey stop it
chill out you're gonna drop a little bit
yeah there we go
I might have to be just jumping at
spines on the other side but we're gonna
try this anyway okay he's not shaky do
you think it's at the head it is but I'm
as you can might have gone the wrong way
I can't hold on to that though oh well
you get a reset over there yeah that's
what I'm trying to get to I'm just he's
shaking along the way there
[ __ ] okay okay I did go the wrong way
didn't I no I got to go to his neck
are you gonna get up there though oh
yeah oh yeah yep
nailed it dude I am going the wrong way
I think I think I suppose to go the
other way we'll try that what is
happening oh yeah I think I gotta go
over his spines that sucks
that was a pretty courageous jump there
yeah we are currently playing on the ps4
problem
as Mike mentioned it's still a little
clunky but better than expected control
wise I think I gotta jump the spinal
things here yeah I at least I hope
figured you out you Beast
it was way more complicated I thought it
would it would be give me your goddamn
skull oh you know they he sensed it with
his eyes yeah I know I stabbed his but
point already he looks angry that was a
good one oh I know he's asked it oh I
just want ask to mouth no just kidding
sorry Oh probably kids watching yeah
so how likely is it that he throws you
off is it only based on the fact that
you were on the outer right and you're
gripping you're fine but okay it's like
right now you're like future Colossus
colossi will freak out more in the later
stages another life oh he's still alive
yeah so a lot of we don't know I don't
know if they feel yet all will shake
will just shake uncontrollably and it
does cost more grip to hold on while
they're shaking ah do down
two to six more or two - yeah two to six
more to go that we can actually show you
know I'm trying to think of a game that
had comparable boss fights when this
first came out like I remember God of
War two started off with that Colossus
of Rhodes fight and that was pretty epic
for the first 20 minutes of the game
Ron you cannot run from the shadows I
don't check out I remember it's puing
others face like that in the past like
vomiting yeah back into his subconscious
I don't know that I'm gonna waste time
doing that huh yeah it's fine oh yeah it
feels good and it's a tough camera to
work with for a game like this like I
had it's tough to make a camera for a
game of this scale but it's working
pretty well aiming the bow doesn't feel
like you're aiming a duty obviously
b-b-boom I believe it's the same
philosophy so yep there are a few like
six that got cut from the original game
people are hoping that people are hoping
that uh there they would add those back
in I don't believe they have that that'd
be cool though
Michael Holmes will have and DANC will
have more info on the lobby this week
prefer to stay tuned Jason Bourne
doesn't support the killing of innocent
creatures of God wrong game for you then
probably
sweet on to the third one
he Candy's got it some ups I know right
so working on those calf lips I wasn't
even paying attention where he said the
next one would be I know what the next
one is but it looks like we're crossing
the bridge anyway thank you Eric
that's for the wind thank you also we're
not reviewing the game just so you guys
know yeah so later on you to start going
toward lakes and deserts and [ __ ] like
that you want to try it you want to see
real quick if they have a night mode so
what it was a distant way but in filter
oh that would make sense
vivid well warm cool complimentary mono
we could play in black-and-white
frigid wow there's a make it more cool
there's a lot that's cool yeah there are
a lot it's like a is this supposed to be
like a screen flow it's like a VHS or
something are not even it's like a old
film there's night night let's do one
boss on night intensity turn that up
film grandma I can't like that feeling
I'm gonna turn it off for this though
okay sweet thank you whoever pointed out
to me oh yeah sorry I missed the chat
name there for the night mode but I
appreciate it say something there are
sixteen colossi and Nightcrawler as apex
of ellcrys says we are only trashed if
we can't defeat a Colossus so we're
doing fine oh did you see that what was
that the screen just like got really
dark and I oh I guess that's supposed to
uh
Kenpachi 87 I'm not sure if we'll do a
let's play of a the whole thing
necessarily when Rob we're gonna do
something related to another oh wait is
this just gonna bring me back down to
the beach the beach
I believe it is I might have to go back
up there he went the wrong side you
think it's on the other side I think so
he feels a little unresponsive hey if
you get tired play on warm setting
science ah gross still fine horse
question is where did the puzzle
elements start to come in for this game
once you start fighting harder Dez's
walkthroughs we're currently playing a
Shadow of the Colossus it's the remake
and it's coming off February the 6 we're
currently searching for the third
colossi ah there we go
Colossus there Colossus whole third
Colossus yeah have the map to show it
okay I mean it's pretty yeah it shows
you where the unbox is now it shows you
where you killed the last yeah unlock
the spots you've been in here all right
across this barrage this is definitely
not Monster Hunter world but that game
comes out at the end of this week
Thursday Friday yeah but I think our
review stuff comes up Thursday so we
might be able to screen one Thursday
we'll try to get you guys some late game
so this does feel like a faithful remake
like it's a gross still I'm not this bad
at steering horses and auger oh just
feels very like a horse might I guess I
don't know that he's not your best bud
yet that life will do everything you say
oh you're thinking like breath of the
wild aren't you huh huh huh actually
hated horses in breath of the world I do
I don't hear they ever use them because
I just hate it they like to feed it the
purpose of the game the only fun horse
was the giant horse that horse was
pretty cool horse was huge you never got
the giant horse in breath of the wild
it's like it might be like Ganon's horse
it's huge it's like
what boss looks best that's hard to say
Tevin we've only seen two Mike can maybe
speak to his favorite boss from the old
game but like many people I would
probably say the desert snake thing is
mine how far in is that the 12 is up no
no no it's like around the clip the next
one I think it's a fourth or fifth when
you first go to the lake that one's
awesome because that kind of hopefully
we got there then yeah we should I'm
making a big promise there I like it I'm
confident I think I'm going into this
valley I could be wrong though some of
this like later in this game it would
not be that fun of a game to stream
because of how long it can take to get
to some of the colossi I think he's in
here it's not that dual right I think
I'm not doing an agro that's a rock yeah
yes it's kind of my fault although he
should be smart enough to god night well
looks amazing bear with me I might be
going the wrong way
I think I'm good that's interesting
though that you say that it's like like
pretty linear boss wise but that might
be confined or anywhere you want like
that would just make me feel like why
not let you just see what's he doing why
not just let you do I think I'm here
oh yeah this is the one this is the
[ __ ] this is like the iconic one
that's on the cover and [ __ ] nice with a
long Club see you could see the biomes
already starting to change like a swamp
and then there's like an arena up here
that we're gonna fight up in there you
go let's see yeah the burden of sunken
graveyard who just said that
hey thanks panel car battery factory
that is a good one I'm gonna see ya girl
yeah you're you're done you're over
leaves grow he got us where we needed to
I don't think we could
Tim that's impressive jump from yeah
we're late
Blue Point has come a long way
fine lettuce - here wait a sprint I
don't think there is I think it's just
like swim faster yeah only on a grow I
think I can do that
anyway the chat news I think I just got
to be patient swim
darkness is a shadow of the colossus the
remake version coming out to ps4 in
about two weeks February the 6th thanks
for you breaker for tuning in I
appreciate it appreciate all you guys
tuning in today with me and Mike we see
him every day at 11 a.m. so if you guys
haven't followed her subbed you should
do that to get notified when we go live
bunch of fun stuff coming this week we
got Dragonball Fighters of course
getting released we won't even be able
to stream that a little early certain
parts of it
Monster Hunter world of course later
this week someone was telling me cod
resistance stuff starts this week to
today and checking that out yeah see if
thieves beta this one margaritas got a
lot to look forward to this weekend nice
nailed it
whoo jump high enough here we go jump
backwards or over or do a little dolphin
flip nah go around a lot I think so
check this out
can you get to the top two then get a
running start to that's what I think I'm
gonna oh there's some good call
I think no oh so you can't go that way I
guess not my grip can you jump far
enough
oh maybe down to that stuff did that do
the greenery oh I like it though that
would have been more obvious I guess do
you think that was how you're supposed
to do yeah I think I just didn't trust
his jump distance so I mean we did say
he had nothing to see up here and this
looks cool yeah so this is the one
you've probably seen before like I'm the
cover and stuff this is where I would
have expected a door to close in like
Dark Souls yeah what's it called
traverse the night nightmare fun
I know it's bought something fun or just
long if you can't me I changed my mind
you can't make this jump cheer up dad
hey we made it we made it is this one
like is the this is the first that
overtly attacks you Oh cuz he's got like
a sword or club yeah
damn dude that looks sick I don't know I
gotta make sure I don't run off the edge
because I've done that before
alright come on swing swing you guys
tell me if this night mode are you guys
cuz we'll switch it we'll probably
switch it back after this there's a lot
of different visual filters we can put
on that mode looks pretty cool
fighting this guy under the moonlight
it's pretty scary but I just don't know
how that translated over stream if it's
too dark so he did not do the right
swing take the shader huh please even a
stab should I turn it's too dark
yeah I take it off alright thank you I
figured it kind of looked that way or I
don't know pick one yeah we'll go to
none here
there you go alright here we're back to
normal night mode here for me as well
yeah
yeah I guess you don't have like a dot
it's just more like a you gotta get up
get the [ __ ] yeah got it no thought I
had it closed no I'm on I'm on that
balance dude doc you got the balance
what is he doing
get up you piece him jump why won't he
jump Keiko moving there we go I'm moving
around you kind of find about it all
right going around it's gotta be a spot
that's open right oh [ __ ] no I got it I
know I gotta have him hit the pedestal
in the middle first so I can climb up
it's all coming back to him now guys
yeah whoa all right all right we're good
work so he'll hit this and then his arm
will crumble then I can go up Oh like
the ring around his arm yeah yeah so
it's getting a little bit more get it
get it get it swing swing swing my
parents see while we're dealing with
earlier oh no I think he followed you
damn it I guess I gotta wait you got a
you got a really but a fine line oh just
getting out of the way at the last
minute please name hope that context
yours are horrible yeah I think
again at that time still not like right
past it a little too far yeah swing you
jerk
damn the hair that's right Kevin Garcia
oh so it does eventually give you hints
oh you just ate it and still no
I'll use the circled I just then there
is an actual dodge yeah oh I thought I
wasn't I I try not to use it because it
uses a little bit of I guess I'll use it
I gotta go like Stan now I think see
early right yeah yeah really you gotta
be not afraid
so I said after the sword jump on the
leg there's nothing that you know I'm
doing it right I'm just gotta let him I
gotta let him hit this first no no we
he's Mike is pretty sure about crawling
up the sword but he needs angelos to him
I got a haven't hit that thing so that
it'll crumble that little armor ring
because he's basically getting blocked
from climbing his arm so I'm gonna stop
being a chicken it's kind of hard man
this guy's got big club that he wants to
smash it I don't know like I don't know
like what you want me to do I can't find
it if his armor so I'll have him come
closer to this edge and then I'll get
him someone saying there's a hole in his
wrist they can climb up would hit him in
the middle I got it we're fine okay so
now all cuz there was this little spot I
don't know if you could climb through it
but there was a little thing but all
right this should be good we'll go with
the Trident with that Mike Scott here
there we'll need some rocks yeah hey
just maybe you should stop calling out
everybody yeah I got Weiss I could feel
no I like feeling their fire here we go
don't worry guys there we go I got this
[ __ ]
ooh he's an effort effort now huh yeah I
am
got it
it's alright I killed I know I thought
you actually got hate there for a second
I was like did you just die Mike that
would be funny but he did mess me up so
you can see now that hey people I know
what I'm doing oh yeah this is his wrist
is off yeah what happened for half of
its off no now I can fine yeah yeah for
sure
what are you doing hey cap zero I'm
gonna do it right way um I hit the stone
again nice
I'll have them come this way here we go
we're also just like showing how big the
boss is no I almost I was just waiting
for him that he's gonna but it was
something like though coming through
right I buy it right here buddy take
your best shot swing at me
I swing
Oh sick I'll use the cheat code now
there isn't she nice JK though John Dean
and he's got a swing at some point right
well I think he's just waiting for it to
line it up yeah the only swings when
he's sure oh don't hit that thing don't
do it yeah all right here we go
that's what you get that's par that's
Karma yeah whatever that was Karma
100% karma right there here we go
I got just that don't worry it's on the
it's on the timing here we go
yeah we're up hey I think we're good
I just don't wanna I don't wanna I don't
want to jinx it I'm gonna rest on his
shoulder oh my god oh god yeah they are
remaking it BluePoint and japan studios
comes out yeah February the 6th I don't
know want to risk resting on his arm
right now why cause he might knock you
off Mike I'm in shape I'm digging up to
just know I think it happened right here
is fine yeah he's got good core strength
you know he's gonna find his balance you
have to go to his lower back first or
just stuff on his head I forget I mean
it should be cool asking the wrong guy
thinking out loud um does he have more
than one vital point I wonder it might
be down on his waist I'm waiting for the
game to tell me lower back yeah it'll
head I'll just go straight to his head I
mean it doesn't get a certain order I
can just do it yeah so okay
oh he's shaking no he's not airs one yet
I mean the head usually does it yeah see
this is where I get stuff cuz he's over
well you know what if someone was
climbing on your head I'm pretty sure
you wouldn't like it so he puts up a
little more fight as far as the shaking
goes oh look at his eyes is there ever
like a uh I mean like maybe this is
spoilers but does Colossus that like I
don't want to do this again nice shaking
oh no no I'm good okay they're gonna be
able to regain is there ever like a
colossus that will smack himself in the
head to try to get you they do some
pretty funny stuff later on well I
wouldn't know I don't think they like
slap themselves or anything cuz I was
just watching one punch panic I don't
know if you watch one punch man but I'm
watching it again and in the first
episode of the second episode but
there's a huge guy that's like like an
enemy like a monster and like part of
the schtick is that his brother is the
scientist that kind of created him and
his brothers on his shoulder but then
the hero guy comes to destroy him and
his brother his low brother that's on
his shoulder back this is all gibberish
to me he's listening but it's yes he
says kill that guy on your shoulder but
he kills his brother on accident I'm
pretty sure mrs. chats one punch man so
they'll get they'll get me I feel like I
talk a lot of anime on these streams and
like I'm it's like really me and like a
few people in chat but it is what it is
huh Oh full hit oh that might be the end
of his vital point yeah for that one
yeah alright I think it's on his lower
back
okay hey you're making me anxious I got
this covered we're good I've never seen
him do the flip animation I thought you
were gonna fall off the bed okay
well he's never done that whatever all
right think go down his other arm now as
soon as wrist or lower back chat remind
me wrist or lower back or no stomach its
stomach I think okay no I have no idea
I'm just saying that I gotta jump up
there also it's like my anxiety is the
same as like when you're in a car and
you know you're not the driver you're
the passenger and you see like you're
gonna get real close to the car in front
of you but the person driving obviously
has knows how hard they have to brake
etc to play I feel a little scared
watching them break and I'm like I'm
like pressing the brake as if I could
break but then I can't yeah it's on the
back waist so lower back lower back
either way I'm gonna drop okay Lauren so
I got a drop down either way thanks for
the chat that and you didn't make me
sound like a fool talking about one
point god Dan so Lexi said jumping for
the right arm is the easiest for that
one yeah that's how I was trying to do
yeah it's nice
don't worry boys I'll let him swing
again I'll start from the bottom
so then I could just jump straight to
his stomach from his right arm yeah
belly punch him well we're gonna toss
away Department he swung really far for
me that time I don't think I'm gonna
make it up this time
you gotta believe like we keep on it
yeah now yes you go fine
it's on the [ __ ] stamp
is it yeah it's lower back or stomach so
I said lower back I gotta get out of
that waist pipe my swing is so far from
me right now I don't know his act maybe
maybe the fact that I'm not got so much
damage to his head he's less accurate
know what I'd like to pick a point uh
there is a season to have one punch is
this being directed by a different
studio which causes me to be a little
bit worried but enough about one punch
back to the Colossus fight boss is
number three here in the swing we're
hoping to get two Colossus 500 it'll be
fine oh we got like half an hour we're
good how's that any move now you did
that first I just took most to him I'm
gonna get over here
can't see far yeah now I'm doing it too
far I used to be I was not doing it
close enough
sprint ski boy look Oh Oh possibly saved
okay I'm pressing X there we go Jesus
it's just kind of well like you said
there's gonna be a little bit of the jig
should be able to jump from his platform
thing right here so it should be set I'm
gonna go around the other side of this
you do you Mike
I will nailed it
okay so [ __ ] set for stomach
yeah I got it his belly button oh that
sucks I want to I get stabbed I don't I
mean I wouldn't wanna get stabbed
anywhere
it hurts gushing out shadow blood we are
being we are playing on a pro the
atomizer for those pretty bad
see also I like that this like his
center of gravity so it's not shaking as
much when you're on his extremities you
get [ __ ] flung around and three down
see you
and time to spew more shadow while I
guess childhood memories says Eevee yeah
I like that I don't know whose twitch
channel has that that ripped with a
gravestone with her tombstone with the
Bible that's cool run Mike maybe you can
avoid it so fort Colossus is uh I
thought I'm awake
it was the belly so that's wrong that
was just back no as someone said it's
the back I want the belly I know that's
the belly
that was the stomach yeah I don't know
what Michael Lexi says that it's the
same issue of not knowing if you're safe
to climb up or not so your character
gets locked into the climb upstate yeah
I mean he's kind of like shifting
between yeah like a fear if you're
standing next to fur on the platform and
I feel like sometimes it didn't know
whether I was three of them now trying
to climb or not I'm guessing by the end
of it there will be sixteen people
around us
spaghetti time yes palms are sweaty
fourth colossus so what is there a crab
Colossus
the next bow is Santa Greenfield Rose
and guiding graves kind of looks like a
giraffe in that statue was probably not
oh is this the bug thing
maybe uh let's try not to talk about
spoilers guys it's a shadow a freak oh
no it's not it's four years after Eko
came out just in case oh I'm not sure
what they're talking let's not do let's
not do spoilers in case for some of
those people they're gonna play yes for
the first time let's try yeah my friend
crossing that bridge again the storyline
is pre eco a storyline I thought they
meant release release date yeah cuz eco
you can play cooperatively with a
so once that it's the crab yeah it's
like that I thought I was like a praying
mantis thing also Kevin things were
pretty much dead sea yeah I hate that
argument that like I hope they they like
I hope when they remake it they don't
like take away those bugs cuz that's
what made the game grey it was like no
it's not like really you're they're
gonna put that much money into remaking
a game and you think it's better to
leave some of those bugs like if you're
that trapped in nostalgia then go ahead
but I'd rather they fix this stuff if I
wanted to play a faithful original
catalyst I would play the original
shadow of Colossus I don't I don't get
that so like I don't get that argument I
mean I get people like think it's like
it's nostalgic Jake it's that but like
maybe it's a better historical record
just if you don't spend the money on a
ps2 or ps3 and play those versions
because like that's my I get I get why
people like so what are your thoughts
have like a game like fallout for that
cuz like a lot of people like part of
the like the [ __ ] of it was people just
accepting the fact that that's just like
fallout you know what I mean no no I
think they're saying like there were
like
that's just cuz it's a massive game I'm
talking about like there were just
actual fundamental design issues with
this with the original game mechanically
that actually hindered it and people
said they forgave it but they said was
part of the game but like if you're
making it for a ps4 in modern day I'd
rather they wouldn't I don't know yeah
pretty sure that's the one that put the
wrong trying to like on the right way
thing what they're here give a soul back
to yeah Walter White said you had the
bedico and then you get co-op yeah
spoilers the ending is depressing I
think I'm gonna write away but we'll
figure it out it's just not it's not get
to details I know it's near the graves
right or those not graves they said it
was in the meadow yeah might not be
going the right way right now figure it
out
I mean it's glowing yellow which I think
usually means them huh
I met to go back and around me go around
I was liking climbs and stuff here bear
with me yellow means you're in the
shadow and the sword won't work
gotcha okay cool thanks Lexi I think I
am in the wrong spot oh I'm not even
gonna bother writing him out of this
Canyon I'm gonna call him yo Eric this
game tho yeah
I'll have him follow this is the wrong
Colossus yeah we have just realized
thank you for the information
time to find the crab danny has a bird
that is the bird leader
I really like the bird that is that
fifth or sixth chat we're trying to get
to five right what's up David Nico from
Romania I'm bagging nope still shadow
alright you have to point it at the rock
and it looked like it was like ya might
have to climb or just go around the
other way
yeah I don't think I can climb that
stuff sky is 100 we have pretty much the
like a review copy that we're allowed to
preview we can only show up to the first
date bosses we're not gonna get that far
today probably the fourth or fifth boss
we're on the 4th about to be on the 4th
so hoping to get to the fifth I guess I
was going the wrong way I don't know if
I can climb or fifth is the bird one
did I just go the complete wrong way
back there
I forgot how to get to the I'm trying to
see if the chats helping out here yes
that's a dangerous game yeah I don't
remember how to get to every Colossus
it's gonna be boring to watch I think I
thought I was going the right way but I
maybe there's nothing to go Lexi how do
we get to the fourth fourth boss here
man
it's been a while okay good I'll try
that way I think it's I just go straight
through these canyons that someone say
tower area yeah I think I it is I think
it's that look mound where that thing
like peeks into the tunnels well I know
how to beat that one mmm okay so many
there's go this way instead we're only
streaming in 1080 so you're not getting
a 4k experience for those we're talking
about 4k back out of the field then take
a left just up this way
aha thank you so that's it's not a
design flaw at all but later on when
you're unlike the 12th Colossus some of
them get really tough to find and I
think that's when the controls start to
annoy me because I get that like aggro
is that lizard there we go
mmm I see a tail there we go
nice got it so it gives you more
gripping I guess more endurance I forgot
if that gives me better health or
whatever I grow I'm holding triangle
he's got a like a car he's at rev it up
he reminds me of the Last Guardian
that's the reason I get why the Last
Guardian like I get why a tricot didn't
respond to you really well all the time
but I hated it so much if I wanted up
like I have pets that don't always
listen I don't want to do that in a game
is normal it's a I think someone said
that was a normal lizard it does nothing
yeah just picked up I just want to kill
him it's the globe a lizard I think it's
your grip is this no this is the one I
was thinking of yes it is okay yeah this
one's this one took me a while to figure
the first time I played the game because
there's you have to really wait in there
for a while Mena's but the white tail
he's annoying
just like horses are always annoying I
mean red dead they were good what else I
don't know they were fine and why I mean
Zelda yeah yes
bred the wild they were supposed to be
kind of unwieldy that was the point you
get them to trust you more oh mama I
yeah is that the nickname for this one
Skyrim horses I didn't use Skyrim horses
enough I remember the horse armor that
was that first that was the infamous DLC
right have you played the PSP version
yeah and that one felt very much like
this this has me if it looks better this
looks an infinitely better but it still
feels kind of janky I wonder if I have
to go down first this is really giving
me flashbacks I got beat the original
game twice on ps2 maybe
who he's in there no but you come down
here to get him lure him out lies
dormant might be yeah he's over in this
like I don't want to get on Agra man so
once I go to the tunnels that hope just
did okay I think I gotta get a get him
to come out first over here alright I'll
go yeah there is Haho see he's pretty
he's kind of small but they're the last
one but I think the biggest one is 12 or
something I forget it's massive
Chico has a beautiful creature but he is
such a trouble to handle yeah and that's
the point and I respect that I just I
personally didn't want to deal with that
yeah four legs
Yesi I always like call him afraid
mantis but I guess Obama and he is more
like a llama see you see one all right
this one is when you start to use the
environment a lot more so I'm gonna get
off a girl pretty soon okay Andre it's
like no you're not the record is holding
triangle that whole time no you don't
need a girlfriend
no I know I'm just saying I just say
like he's like no you do need me man
like the crab yeah he's like a no I
always said grab a llama mantis go
I realize that doesn't cook trying to do
our best we know there's a Billy we're
screenshot
Oh danke Colossus I hope you're okay
I'll grow so much made a rainbow succeed
reference please don't get stopped on
isn't he like dad Pechanga he's one of
the worst operators yeah but he's like I
mean the chunk all right so what's the
key here back so you want to get him to
look like peer into one of these old
tunnels yeah people might could be
annoying to watch because sometimes I
don't get him to look directly we in
here sir
she's over there right now and then I
gotta come up behind him like a seahorse
was like no yeah what is up Jesse Ibero
but do you think you got him to like do
his thing
almost I think maybe have to wait down
there longer cuz he does he like you see
you see his the furrows that could
crouched it down like that yeah go
I wish haha guy that went smoother than
I thought it might cuz that sometimes
she doesn't always crack you as well as
I might like him to I'm gonna rest once
I get up here there's one on his neck
right yeah there was one like right yeah
right there oh he feels me got the red
kind of like missed ya quiet
No No maybe assert a new way of helping
you no I mean the other ones weren't
either the first boss have it ready
really yeah the very very first flossin
so this is not gonna be the only one you
can tell there's one has had two boys on
it I'm just drifting over to little chat
alright feeling good about hopefully
game to the fifth boss now I'm getting
in that guy fifth losses down
is this even a weak point oh that Lord
is head I don't think I'm doing anything
anymore yes sorry I gotta go just have
in my bed now we're at the weak point oh
so this is like a slight mechanical
tweak I guess so yeah I don't even know
if this is the last one I don't remember
well you'll find out once you know that
you're not doing damage anymore right
yeah I mean it'll bit literally
disappear this might be it I don't think
there's much else since body does but
it's interesting the back is still there
though usually they that was no so I
think that was it wasn't an actual like
relic or a parabolic looking thing it
was an end it was just like a spot that
made him lower his head like oh my god I
think this is last one just his head
then so this boss is probably more about
figuring out how to get to his yes so
like that wasn't the first time I ever
played his boss took me forever
so like I don't know maybe they updated
it but I remember having a problem with
if you go to the key is getting him to
follow you really close and then going
in a tunnel because if you just go and
wait he'll just wait in the middle and
kind of like not know which one you're
kind of at right like to locate you and
see ya
cool when we put him on it up there I
did last week so that you guys could be
like two people's game playing here
although I haven't been looking up there
because it also like track it's not
necessarily the best spot work with what
you got
12:15 is sweet so we have time I didn't
either the fifth one is amazing it's one
of my favorite ones and I know how to
get there cuz I accidentally just went
there oh that was the one I blew the
water corn you Chad okay hopefully but I
don't think he'll be that hard fine it's
just a massive plate you gotta find them
that's like a sunken in graveyard
you know how long this game would be I
mean on average the first few have taken
me so we could be heard once a relay
with my 15 minutes to kill but I think
the game itself could be around 10 hours
your first sign of you a little more a
girl loves her too
yes it is weird people are mentioning
another it's not as hazy as they
remember and I did like that back in a
day but I think that also might have
been to cover up some of the fact that
the textures were not - Theo says 9 to
13 hours give or take so when L say 9:00
to 10:00
so next colossus a br
it's probably more than 10 hours or
first-time credence but it's absolutely
one it's well worth the $60 it is 60
right three mess Oh some cool thing it's
not really what else don't check yeah
the bagger D roll it does he's $39.99 oh
[ __ ]
okay cool no 4939 oh I'm look what am I
looking at that was like a special
edition 40 bucks
yeah it's 100% worth that I would pay 60
don't be saying those kinds of things
Mike what I'm not I'm trying to be a
shill I'm just saying I would pay no I'm
not not saying you're being a show I'm
just like that's how the companies get
away with charging 60 whatever I know
this game this okay okay you're right
you know what I mean though like yes
like you're right okay make the best we
want this is uh okay you don't know
what's gonna be about to happen right no
I don't okay this this Colossus should I
think this Colossus Willie sell you on
the game okay if you haven't been
already all right
but yeah for those watching I do
it feels faithful to the original with
the controls but it it like a grow is
already annoying me and I get that
that's part of it and I like it in a
nostalgia sense
I do wish he would be a little more
fluid but it's hard to complain when the
bosses are still this game still like
amazing I'm like still curious if it
feels like a masterpiece and I want to
say the special editions like kind of
hard to get because I feel like Peter
was trying the other day and those sold
out now don't quote me on that quickest
anyway from like 9 hours link here yeah
13
I know you can pre-order a special still
so what comes in I'm trying to find out
so in-game digital extras each info
cloak of fate spotted Stieg aggro skin
he's like custom pious yeah I guess
spotted version to custom ps4 themes
yeah do paste are on Twitch the controls
do feel a bit janky I I'm sure if I went
back to play the original they would not
be that or it would not be as bad as
that but they do feel like lexing the
chat had mentioned that it does have a
problem it's kind of like the original
assassin's creed's where it thinks I'm
climbing when I'm not trying to and vice
versa and that's becoming a little bit
frustrating but it's not hindering my
enjoyment of it and that last Colossus I
think would take you much longer if you
didn't play the original like just
figure out how to just to get up onto
him no we're not gonna finish this today
I don't even think I could finish the
game if I took all day to finish it yeah
also we were only allowed to show up to
the 8th Colossus anyways here we go
Mary's at her job for the person that
asked Mike where Mary is Oh
also just to finish artist postcards
printed manual colossi avatar set for
ps4 physical world map colossi stickers
steelbook collectors case with outer
sleeve I think that's everything
hopefully that's in the special edition
which is $10 worth I bear with me and
forgetting how to get in you don't go
over there I think so that reflections
mess with me and someone else I mention
you swim faster underwater this kind of
looks okay oh god I love this
alright climb up now and tell me sell me
on this all right you'll see
so you know some of the Colossus cosmic
fly right yeah alright this is your
first taste of that alright but also
just this environment right here that
it's in is just absolutely gorgeous
somebody mentions the sunken graveyard I
never really yeah yeah if you want to
come to this game fresh I would stop
watching right here although this isn't
an amazing Colossus so this will be a
spoiler warning stop watching this if
you want to this is a ps4 Pro but we're
only streaming 1080 60 but according to
Mike this is the one that's gonna get me
dude yeah he's got a little tail too
yeah this is getting onto this Colossus
is probably one of the most invigorating
things I remember from playing this game
back when I was 14 at the time I think
that's cool man
oh it's cool so you think you know how
to get on it by looking at it right now
right he's got a long tail right no no
way no naw dude all right let's go oh
[ __ ]
good start oh I could just jump sorry
looks like oh um okay that was just to
start the boss yeah I haven't really he
I don't think he's even noticed me I'm
gonna get onto one of these uh platforms
so you swim faster if you're underwater
I believe yeah you do
this is the music here is awesome people
have mentioned if you want to turn up
the game play a little bit I'll just say
anything sorry check
all right so now to remember whether
that's a little loud they do a little
higher than that so here we go do I get
into one of these or one of them big
platform so he noticed it me or you know
what I could just I'm thinking out loud
sorry oh sorry just
hey yeah there we go alright so bear
with me I either have to stand here or
on the tall one I believe it's nope
didn't do all right okay I got it I'm on
the right I'm on the right path though
okay
oh you red eyes
yes dick and then the winds pushing me
so I can't move right now like he's just
[ __ ] before oh [ __ ]
turn it oh my gosh so much okay sweet
I'm glad I was on the right putt oh he's
I'm almost off it's okay your straw man
climb oh I'm not even on the FIR no
you're not you're like rock climbing
right there we go there we go there we
go okay where's his his town I got away
from the little I can rest all right yes
good we're good we're good we're good
front runner is a his tail yeah I was
about to say I don't say anything okay
okay that was almost a trick right there
light didn't light up is about there
falling off this Colossus into the water
is also really fun but I won't do that
for times sake but it like can you
imagine like calling into it he was like
I think that's it for that guy I think I
go to his head after this yeah that did
very little oh that's it yeah oh [ __ ]
okay he's still bleeding go go go go I
don't remember the other ones doing that
but they still bleed out like that yeah
okay
oh man I must wind is below me I am
pushing forward as some part as I can
it's nice oh [ __ ]
what are you banks
oh man isn't this unreal [ __ ]
perfectly over some wings [ __ ]
you don't talk it's on his wings all
right I don't know it's weird because
yours can light up till you hat really
close to it right there's nothing on
yeah it might be is out on his playing
it looks a little bit blue the wings
yeah yeah we just thought yeah yeah also
I think someone in chat just mentioned
it so I got out you gotta wait till it
levels out so I can run over the stone
to get there well I could jump I guess
but I'm gonna do it the badass but no
the wings get tough as you can imagine
because he needs them to stay afloat
it's even more I'm gonna run I gotta go
oh [ __ ] that might have been bad that
was bad no I got it
because he almost like flow what's about
to feel a little alright I think that
one's done I think it's one big
Stephanie there oh he's completely
upside down oh so it's both sides I was
gonna say yeah that's that makes sense
also doing this one just made him so
imbalanced I'm not on the fur right now
there we go oh man come on
yes balance out yes no no no I was not
on the fur for most of that all right
where's the water yeah I'm not gonna die
no I know her time I know here we go
here we go it's like you said it's
really cool so I wouldn't mind it should
I go right now yeah just do it no he's
going toward the cliff I gotta wait Oh
coho that would really great you see
that night you can notice he's going
toward the cliff so they got [ __ ] he's
gonna turn ha ha ha oh [ __ ] no Jennifer
god damn it I wasn't alright that I'm
okay that's annoying I'm not trying to
hang onto that ledge I don't know why
it's making me when there's four right
there it's pretty I'll set it sorry oh
he's not this almost bearable still
nothing
Oh God yeah five done I got through five
that's pretty good
that's pretty good what's the sixth one
it's okay so that one is a really fun
like did you expect me to get on by
jumping and grabbing a shoulder no I
respected like you to get to some higher
spot you know to as he kind of jumped
down to then yeah hop down onto him not
be like jump early hey how come you're
not vomiting it's not me yet the black
stick he's underwater somewhere I don't
know where he's landed it's gonna come
from under water I think
[Music]
it's around here somewhere oh that's
tariffs no escape oh oh underwater
version awesome gg gg gg
alright sweet alright cool yeah so
overall controls did take some time to
acclimate to as you could see like later
on the stream it started to get a little
smoother a gross still annoying but
that's part of it ah grow sorry yeah it
feels it was sort of annoying to be
grabbing onto certain things I was not I
didn't even think I was near like those
ledges um but seems like a faithful
remake I guess time will tell as I play
more whether it's to faithful okay we'll
see that's bear we're looking for
amazing yes still like that v Colossus
even the one when he's swinging his
sword like a strategy involved with
having to be a certain distance from him
so he didn't do the stab and generally I
felt I'm really excited to get the next
11 down yeah sounds good so thank you
guys all for tuning in the game comes
out on February the 6th for 39.99 if you
just buy the like regular version the
special editions $49.99 so pretty
awesome that it's not you know full
retail
you said you'd almost be pretty much
willing to pay 60 if it was 60 but it's
cool that it's 40 so you know if you
guys are interested obviously check that
out we'll probably doing some more
preview coverage before it comes out I'm
sure Mike's gonna have maybe a feature
down down the down the road and yeah
stay tuned tomorrow we're gonna stream
some more stuff tomorrow I think we're
gonna check out the overwatch world map
it's gonna be out tomorrow I think the
new skins as they've been showing them
Blizzard has been showing them we'll
check those out it would be prime me and
Joey and yeah just hit that follow
subscribe button if you haven't and
until next time guys have a good one
Mike thanks for playing yeah hell of a
job hey it got better yeah yeah I'm just
like if anything four out of the five
bosses were like you know and it's like
kind of after not playing for so long
like remembering yeah I mean like
getting mechanics I don't member how to
but uh yeah see you guys next time
thanks so much later
[Music]